lundi dernier durant la première fenêtre
de lancement de la méga fusée Artemis 1
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
massées à proximité de Cap Canaveral
pour assister au spectacle Son repartis
déçus
cinq jours plus tard la fusée toujours
sur le pas de tir et la NASA se prépare
pour un nouvel essai
l'agence spatiale a résolu les problèmes
techniques observés au début de la
semaine et la météo serait favorable
mais encore une fois il faudra se
croiser les doigts
la NASA qui avait pris du retard depuis
la mise au rancart des navettes
spatiales a mis la barre très haute avec
son programme de retour à la lune je
pense qu'ils ont voulu vraiment frapper
un grand coup effectivement en allant
sur la Lune
pour parce que il y a c'est cette je
dirais cette guerre entre guillemets
géopolitique qui est très très
importante et d'arriver à faire les
premiers quelque chose ça montre
l'avancée technologique d'un pays oui
qui volera sans équipage est un monstre
un appareil plus puissant que les
énormes saturnes 5 du programme Apollo
avec ses quatre moteurs de navette
spatiale ré-usinés et l'équivalent d'une
piscine olympique de carburant brûlé en
8 minutes elle va atteindre la vitesse
vertigineuse de 27000 km à l'heure une
fois en orbite on va relâcher la capsule
Orion et son module de service européen
aurions va d'abord rejoindre la lune
puis l’orbité plusieurs fois avant de
revenir sur Terre 36 jours plus tard
protégé par le plus grand bouclier
thermique je me conçu
on prévoit lancé Artémis 2 le premier
vol habité en 2024 avec catastronautes à
bord dont un Canadien
en parallèle les Etats-Unis le
partenaire vont amorcer la construction
du Gateway le futur station spatiale
lunaire c'est à partir du Gateway que
des navettes vont transporter les
astronautes et l'équipement nécessaire
pour assurer une présence humaine
permanente sur la lune puis
éventuellement sur la planète Mars
on sait que le chemin pour aller sur
masse c'est pas forcément la ligne
droite c'est vraiment d'aller sur la
Lune et de profiter du peu d'attraction
de la gravitation sur la lune pour s'en
servir comme base de lancement ou base
de relais pour pouvoir aller sur Mars
mais la facture sera salée à ce jour le
programme amorcé sous l'administration
bouche a déjà coûté plus de 90 milliards
de dollars et le lancement d'Artémis 1 à
lui seul plus de 4 milliards
les Américains ne sont également plus
seuls dans la course vers la lune la
Chine est aussi sur la ligne de départ
la NASA devrait aussi surveiller ses
arrières la très innovante compagnie
américaine space ex développe
actuellement sa propre fusée l'énergie
Starship qui contrairement Artemis sera
entièrement réutilisable donc beaucoup
moins coûteuse à opérer ici normand
Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal